[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce dernier c'est
huit sports de la saison tout de suite
le sommaire de votre magazine
multisports tour d'horizon aujourd'hui
des meilleurs moments de cette année
sportive dans les yvelines ne
reviendront notamment sur les montées de
l'équipe senior du sky rugby du désir
handball club ou projecteur également
dans ce magazine sur la nouvelle
dimension de l'open de france de golf en
un an de la ryder cup en france cette
saison a également été marquée par de
nombreux records dans le département
nous prendrons la direction d'ubs et
l'autre hymne national de saint quentin
en yvelines
la structure a réalisé la meilleure
affluence pour un match de handball
féminin en mars dernier le vélodrome a
également été le théâtre d'une
incroyable performance qui repousse les
limites du corps humain robert marchand
105 ans réalisée début janvier un record
de leur offre sur la piste
saint-quentinoise en prend tout de suite
la direction de plaisir pour commencer à
ce best-of la ville a connu cette année
une saison historique au niveau sportif
le plaisir rugby club a validé sa montée
en fédérale 2 avec un quart de finale en
championnat de france
mais le prc n'est pas le seul club à
s'être illustré dans la ville le plaisir
handball club va également montée en
nationale 3 après avoir terminé la
saison avec une seule défaite au
compteur
nous les avons suivis à pendant sur leur
dernier match en mai dernier à regarder
plaisir termina plus belle saison de son
histoire par une victoire assurée de
monter pour la première fois en
nationale 3 les jaunes est loin se sont
imposés lors de l'ultime journée contre
draveil dans un match sans enjeu le
score 34 à 31
le base nous on n'aime pas perdre et on
voulait pour le dernier match à domicile
madame territoire public
c'était pas notre meilleur match loin de
là mais bon c'était pas l'important le
plus important c'était vraiment y'a riad
trois semaines contre eux et où on avait
à coeur de gagner celui-là et
alors on l'a gagnée pour le public mais
pour nous c'est juste le plaisir va bien
avec cette victoire plaisir termine sa
saison avec un bilan de 20 victoires un
nul et une seule défaite
les statistiques affolantes qui ont
permis à l'équipe de terminer en tête de
prénationale quatre points d'avancé sur
le second rôle et athlétique
cette montée était attendue depuis 13
ans par les supporters donc je pense que
ça représente énormément pour le public
pour le club les anciens du club le tout
les dirigeants les bénévoles les petits
c'est vraiment une grande famille c'est
pour tout le monde
voilà c'est pas que nous c'est pas que
les 12 c'est vraiment un club qui avait
tout ce moment là tous ensemble et à
battante une chose c'est de faire la
fête avec eux ce soir après les
festivités les plaisirs or ont déjà les
yeux rivés sur la saison prochaine est
l'objectif numéro 1 le maintien faut
tout de suite se remettre au travail
parce que tout au moins maintenir
l'année prochaine et puis avait
travaillé
pouvoir continuer à amener le projet et
c'est de mener le plus haut possible
donc le ca récent rapport mais avant de
penser à la saison prochaine place à la
fête
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
autre image de joie mais cette fois ci
dans le monde de l'ovalie le sky rugby
qui était descendu en promotion
d'honneur en 2014 a réussi à valider son
ticket pour la division supérieure
en venant à bout de champagne
saint-andré verger le 19 mars dernier
cette performance méritait bien quelques
fumigènes pour fêter l'exploit les
images sont signés à nicolas d'ombré
trois ans qu'ils attendaient de remonter
en division honneur leur ticket a
officiellement été validée ce dimanche
19 mars
les joueurs du sky rugby ont réussi
cette performance grâce à leur 13e
victoire de la saison en 15 matches
disputés leurs victimes du jour
champagne saint-andré verger et saint
quentinois n'ont pas fait de détails en
leur infligeant une véritable correction
36 à 5 avec six essais inscrits on a su
dominer on a su mettre la main sur le
ballon marquer des essais quand il
fallait marquer des essais quand il
fallait garder la balle peu de fois on
leur a laissé un peu le ballon ils nous
ont quand même mis en danger ça s'est vu
c'était pas une équipe une équipe avec
la victoire assurée non plus rester avec
dix points d'avancé sur le 2e chilly
mazarin le sky rugby ne peut plus être
rejoint et obtient l'une des montées les
plus rapides de cette saison en
ile-de-france s'acceptant dans l'année
ça nous permet de nous préparer mieux
pour les prochaines encore malgré tout
on voit que massy monte en pro d2 la
semaine dernière nous cette semaine donc
voilà c'est très bien comme ça pue c'est
tout on a le temps de on se fait pas
peur au moins cette année donc c'est
parfait ça se prépare
dans les têtes déjà parce qu'on monte de
division c'est une division qu'ils ont
connue avec des difficultés par un
moment donc ça se prépare dans la tête
ça se prépare aussi dans le jeu ça se
prépare
à plein de niveaux même au niveau du
club il ya plein de choses à mettre en
place donc c'est beaucoup de travail
mais ça donne ça donne vraiment envie
d'aller travailler
les dirigeants ont déjà fixé les
objectifs pour la saison prochaine le
maintien en honneur
en attendant les joueurs du sky rugby
peuvent savourer leur exploit des
exploits également chez les jeunes
sportifs du département football le club
des clayes-sous-bois brillé en coupe
gambardella la coupe de france des moins
de 19 ans les clés siens se sont imposés
contre clichy sur seine qui évolue deux
divisions au dessus avant de s'incliner
4 à 3 contre caen au 6e tour
les images ont signé à nicolas d'ombré
les clayes-sous-bois sorte de la coupe
gambardella la tête haute les bleus se
sont inclinés contre caen terme d'un
match très offensif pourtant ce 6e tour
de la coupe de france des moins de 19
ans avait très bien débuté avec un but
du milieu offensif nicolas fadi en
première période
[Applaudissements]
au retour des vestiaires les clients
baisser de rythme et encaissé trois buts
en sept minutes avant de réagir sur
penalty la fin de match est équilibré
les deux équipes trouvent le chemin des
filets score final 4 à 3 la victoire
logique pour eux
oui et non parce qu'en première mi temps
ils ont énormément d'occasions il rappe
ténors mais mans 2-0 à la mi-temps les a
prévenus on l'a redit attention ils ont
eu énormément d'occasions et au pas
cadré en 10 à 8 ans a pas pardonné
il est trop de relâchement bond dans le
temps faibles c'est là où on a pris le
but
et voilà après on a vu on a repris le
contrôle du ballon on a remarqué mais
trop tard malgré la défaite plusieurs
joueurs se sont révélés pendant la
partie c'est le cas de thé au maréchal
surnommé le temps d'un après midi thé ou
neuer en référence au gardien champion
du monde allemand très bon regardez
aujourd'hui qui est très bon toujours et
aujourd'hui je suis fier de lui parce
que ça faisait un très déplacé dernière
que je l'avais en u17
j'attendais un très grand match de lui
un match 100% parce qu'il me fait
toujours des matches à 40% des parades
décisives qui ont enflammé le public du
stade beltramini plusieurs centaines de
supporters avaient fait le déplacement
pour voir la rencontre et encourager les
joueurs on est faire représenter tous
bois on se connaît dans les 64 équipes
et de france en sachant qu'un à plus de
2000 voilà même quand on repartira ils
pourront dire que les clayes-sous-bois
sa part à un match facile
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle campagne en gambardella pour
les clayes-sous-bois il faudra se
reconcentrer dès le week-end prochain
sur le championnat
l'efsc les siens sont actuellement
deuxième de 2e division de district des
grands événements étaient également
organisées dans les yvelines cette année
le vélodrome nationale a accueilli
pendant cinq jours au mois d'octobre les
championnats d'europe de cyclisme sur
piste
une première pour l'enceinte sportive la
france a remporté sept médailles dont
trois en or grâce à la révélation
trappistes benjamin thomas 21 ans le
saint quentinois remporté l'or en
poursuite par équipes le bronze sur le
mien mais l'argent sur l'américaine avec
morgan kneisky au tableau des médailles
la france termine sur le podium
autre événement marquant de cette saison
sportive l'open de france de golf qui
était organisé comme tous les ans sur
les greens de golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines
la compétition a pris cette année un
nouvel essor nouvelle organisation
nouveau parking rénovation de l'hôtel
des joueurs de renom tout cela grâce aux
nouveaux sponsors à chênée qui a rejeté
plusieurs millions d'euros dans le
rendez-vous coup de projecteur l'open de
france 2010 être entre dans une nouvelle
ère le tournoi est passé cette année
sous le pavillon du groupe
d'investisseurs chinois à chine l
entreprise investit dans le rendez vous
saint quentinois et la dotation est
passé à plus de
7 million de dollars le double par
rapport à 2016 nous sommes-nous
fédération ravi de cette évolution
nous sommes ravis de cette montée en
puissance de notre peine nationale et
puis on croise les doigts pour ça se
poursuit dans l'autre tous les tentes du
terme
pour cette édition 2010 est la
compétition a tiré des têtes d'affiché
françaises comme alexander levy au
victor dubuisson et des stars
internationales comme jeune ram ou tommy
fleetwood sur le plan sportif le
rendez-vous également intégrer les rolex
series les meilleurs tournois européens
c'est un superbe événement voilà on a la
chance de faire partie des plus gros
tournois européens
donc pour nous français on est très
heureux d'avoir un tournoi comme ça il a
appris en dimension c'est déjà c'était
déjà un gros tournoi mais là c'est
encore plus gros je pense que c'est
vraiment voilà une des meilleures
éditions qu'on est qu'on ait eu à jouer
au niveau du décor les spectateurs ont
pu voir du changement nouveau parking
nouveau centre de presse rénovation de
l'hôtel les prémices d'une organisation
millimétrée pour la ryder cup qui se
déroulera sur l'albatros en septembre
c'est vrai qu'à une année de la ryder
cup ça nous permet de faire des tests en
grandeur nature
c'est vrai qu'en termes de volume un
open de france n'a pas grand chose à
voir avec une ryder cup il faut
quasiment tout multiplié par dix mais en
tout cas ça nous permet de faire des
tests
le parcours s'est mis lui aussi aux
dimensions de la ryder cup après
quelques modifications 2016 les greens
sont aujourd'hui parfaitement terminé
pour pouvoir accueillir les meilleurs
joueurs du monde c'est une parcours très
bon spectateurs on peut on peut foyer on
peut voir tout ça c'est très bon oeil
par quoi est magnifique un franchement
il améliore ils ont beaucoup amélioré
par la fois d'avant là rien à dire il
est vraiment superbe
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour la
dernière répétition générale sur l'open
de france nouvelle génération
quelques mois avant de recevoir près de
200000 spectateurs pour la ryder cup
2018 les yvelines terre de records
handball féminin les dirigeants d'ici
paraît en réussir à remplir en
intégralité le vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines avec plus de
cinq mille quatre cents spectateurs pour
ce match délocalisé en mars dernier
contre brest une première pour la
structure depuis les championnats du
monde de cyclisme sur piste en 2015
retour sur cet événement 17h30 vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
plusieurs milliers de supporters
arrivent pour assister au choc de d1
féminine entre issy paris et brest voir
les pouvoirs le match du round
on est là parce qu'on a deux joueurs de
hand et que voilà on c'est un événement
dans le coin qui est super sympa donc on
y vient en famille on est content d'être
là du monde il y en avait le match
délocalisé se jouent à guichet fermé
avec 5415 spectateurs dans les travées
cette affluence permet de dépasser le
précédent record pour un match de
handball féminin qui était jusqu'ici
détenu par lente avec 5125 supporters
le record était effectivement
une envie pas forcément l'objectif
principal l'objectif principal c'était
de réussir et vêtements avec tout le
territoire et historique
donc ça c'est là je suis très heureux de
ça les petits quand c'est réussi
pour ce premier match de handball de
l'histoire organisé dans l'enceinte
sportive certains n'ont pas hésité à
faire 600 km pour venir assister à la
rencontre et mettre l'ambiance
nous on suit toujours de très quelques
favoris soutenir le président rhodanien
balle on essaye au décès de faire les
déplacements à chaque fois qu'on peut et
c'est vrai que ici dans cette enceinte
du vélodrome c'est parfait se croirait à
l'aller la bresse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce supporter de brest avait moins le
sourire à la fin de la rencontre le
match s'achève avec une victoire au
forceps d'ici paris contre les bretonnes
sur le score de 24 à 23 selon les
joueuses parisiennes l'appui du public a
été primordiale dans ce résultat une
grosse salle bonne ambiance et je pense
que c'est grâce à 55
aujourd'hui on a ici franchement on
avait à coeur de bien faire ici sur le
stade vélodrome et montrer qu'on a des
parts et le succès rencontré cette année
le vul autour de 50 ans divine et le
club d'issy paris envisage déjà un
second partenariat pour l'année
prochaine cela mérite bien un clapping
et on termine par un autre record son
exploit résonné dans toute la france et
il s'est déroulé sur la piste du
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines en janvier dernier robert
marchand 105 ans a réussi un nouveau
record de l'heure il a réalisé à 22 km
et 547 m devant plus de 1000 spectateurs
encore un grand bar bravo à robert
marchand c'est la fin de ce set 8 sport
merci d'avoir suivi tout au long de
cette saison très bel été sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]